bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france à port du masque
obligatoire en extérieur dont certaines
huiles mais pas dans d'autres que pensez
vous de cette déclinaison territoriale
je pense que le bien sûr on peut se
poser la question si si le port du
masque est efficace à l'extérieur on
aura envie dire non malheureusement il
faut bien s'y résoudre parce que ce
variant micron est tellement contagieux
que dès que les gens ça rapproche les
uns des autres même à l'extérieur il ya
là des risques de contamination dont
bien sûr ces mesures de restriction de
porcs du mince touche d'abord les
grandes villes on a vu sur vos images il
des allées des rues avec beaucoup de
gens donc c'est sûr il ya beaucoup de
virus qui circule dans les particules en
suspension dans l'air et donc bien sûr
les grandes villes sont les premières à
appliquer ces mesures mais je pense que
tous les endroits où il y aura beaucoup
de gens rassemblés à l'extérieur même
s'ils sont pas très statique même s'il
bouge je pense que dans les jours ou les
semaines qui viennent vont être obligés
de porter le masque parce que c'est une
réalité ce virus diffuse à la vitesse
grand v day qui peut passer d'une
personne à l'autre malheureusement alors
c'est le 31e 31 décembre les français
s'apprêtent à faire la fête en dans des
conditions particulières bien évidemment
quels conseils donneriez vous en tant
que médecin pour éviter la contamination
cette soirée on le sait de brassage
écoutez c'est très simple à 3 d'abord
faire un test ou un autotest avant de se
regrouper deuxièmement limiter le nombre
de participants et ce et essayer de se
limiter entre gens si possible vacciner
des gens protéger ou des gens guéri
voilà où des gens tester troisièmement
il faut aérer fréquemment les locaux
parce qu'on peut être porteur même avec
un test négatif on a tout à fait en
phase de début donc il faut aérer les
locaux on sait que les il faut
renouveler l'air dans les pieds soit là
si on applique ces trois mesures test
petit nombre et aération des locaux on
pourra quand même fêté nouvel an un peu
plus tristounette les autres années mais
on fera comme le faire et bien sûr
éviter les grandes embrassades à minuit
quoi on se faire coucou d'un peu plus
loin mais une bonne année de loin cette
année comme l'année dernière de toute
façon alors la menace planant sur les
hôpitaux la menace de la potentielle
saturation ça on le sait est-ce que
craignez-vous que ce soit le cas
justement à la rentrée avec des hôpitaux
français est débordé
alors là la réponse est compliqué on ne
l'a pas tout à fait on sait que le virus
au micron est très contagieux et
peut-être un tout petit peu moins
virulent ou emmène moins de gens à
l'hôpital mais comme il ya beaucoup de
gens qui vont être contaminés bien sûr
que là sur la quantité de gens
contaminés ils réclament beaucoup de
gens qui vont aller à l'hôpital et on
sait malheureusement que ce virus au
micron aime beaucoup cibler les gens non
vaccinés on sait que si ms de reals
d'hôpitaux de soins continus sont pleins
de gens non vacciné malheureusement qui
font des complications et c'est ça la
réalité donc malheureusement il ya trop
de gens non vaccinés donc bien sûr les
hôpitaux vont se remplir avec ce virus
qui est très très contagieux alors la
vaccination justement transformation du
pasa knitter en passe vaccinale dans
quelques temps on voit d'ailleurs que le
gouvernement change de stratégie
pourquoi est ce qu'il y ait encore des
français qui sont réfractaires à ce
vaccin anti qu'ovide
je n'ai pas d'explication je déplore
comme beaucoup je c'est regrettable
parce qu'on voit tous les jours des
effets bénéfiques du vaccin
même si c'est pas un miracle un on ne
tombe le vaccin c'est parce qu'apprendre
qui le protège du virus on peut être
contaminé par le virus heureusement les
gens vaccinés à part un très petite
partie des gens qui sont très fragiles
les gens vaccinés font un simple rhume
voilà est donc en fait l'objectif de
cette vaccination de masse c'est
d'intégrer petit à petit ce virus dans
patrimoni me taire et de faire en sorte
que ce virus tueur au départ ne devienne
qu'un simple virus du rhume il faut que
tous les gens augmentèrent immunité non
pas au contact du virus sauf pour les
jeunes enfants éventuellement mais en se
vaccinant en faisant les trois doses de
vaccin en ayant stocks d'anti corps
important de façon à pouvoir être un
rencontré le virus avec déjà un ce taux
d'anticorps qui nous permettent d'avoir
un coup d'avancé ce virus
alors la vaccination des enfants c'est
facultatif en france ça on l'a vu c'est
donc au bon vouloir des parents comment
on fait pour obtenir leur adhésion
je crois qu'il faut leur expliquer les
tenants et les aboutissants les risques
les enfants bien sûr dans la plupart des
cas feront des maladies tout à fait
bénigne on connaît d'autres maladies qui
ont manié plus de gens à l'hôpital
notamment le virus respiratoire
syncitial qui provoque des fameuses
bronchiolite ont rempli les hôpitaux de
bronchiolite tous les hivers donc ça on
connaît 6e très dangereux pour les
gamins le virus corona même lobby kron
semble heureusement ne pas être aussi
agressif que ça seulement il faut
replacer l'enfant dans sa famille est ce
qu'il ya des personnes fragiles autour
de l'esca des grands-parents sk des
personnages et si l'enfant est juste
tout seul avec des parents jeunes
vacciner on peut très bien dire allez on
laisse immunisés quoi
mais s'il est dans un contexte de vie
sociale importante des familles
important qui est dans un club de sport
club de mussy club d'échecs et ben il
faudra qu'ils qu'on renforce un peu
cette immunité avec un vaccin et je
crois qu'il faut expliquer les choses
simplement aux gens c'est à dire que la
vaccination va préparer l'organisme a
rencontré ce virus à elle va pas être
une protection totale et on sait
maintenant on a un ministre et des
millions et des millions de doses et
milliard de doses de vaccins ces vaccins
ne sont pas dangereux bien sûr ils ont
des petits effets secondaires des maux
de tête des courbatures mais c'est
passager 24 heures après c'est fini il
n'y a pas eu de décès contrairement à ce
qu'on peut raconter ya pas être d'essai
pour le vaccin par contre le virus a tué
des milliards des millions de gens pas
des milliards excusez-moi des millions
de gens on le sait maintenant donc le
danger c'est le virus c'est pas le
vaccin le virus c'est l'aide qui va nous
apporter a affronté le vaccin va nous
aider à affronter ce virus voilà il faut
le percevoir comme ça il faut
l'expliquer comme ça simplement c'est
pas un ennemi pour nous c'est un ami
ennemi justement
pourquoi certains français quand je
parle de français mais dans le monde
entier pourquoi de certaines personnes
ont encore peur de ce vaccin est ce que
il ya eu une mauvaise communication
vous savez en france et ça pas commencer
maintenant s'il est un grand mouvement
antivaccin et la présence du pin
quinzaine d'années on pensait qu'on en
ferait notre affaire on voit bien les
derniers vaccins le papillomavirus et
autres sont rejetés globalement de la
population est maintenant qu défaire
c'est un vaccin qu'il faudrait si
possible donner à toute la population on
voit bien que c'est cette rancoeur
contre les vaccins est tout à fait
évidente voilà donc c'est un travail de
ses poèmes c'est pas liée uniquement
couronne habilleuse c'est je crois
depuis quelques années en france il ya
un grand climat anti vaccin chez les
parents qui dit non non on n'a pas
besoin de ça s'est passé pas loin alors
que les vaccins sont sans doute la
meilleure arme thérapeutique qu'on a par
rapport au virus on n'a pas d'autre on
n'a pas d'autres outils des bureaux et
sa part maintenant des trithérapies
contre le vih contre l'hépatite c compte
hépatite b et éventuellement les autres
virus échappe à tous nos traitements et
quand il passe et à côté de nous on les
attrape donc à part les vaccins on n'a
pas d'autres il faut vraiment que les
gens les parents comprennent 5 lévy que
les vaccins ne sont pas des dangers que
des vaccins ce sont nos amis sont notre
renfort pour affrontrer les virus et
pourtant il ya des parents qu'on
vacciner leurs enfants mais qui refuse
de les faire vacciner contre le covin en
tout cas on est pressé par le temps
merci à vous patrick vogt je rappelle
que vous êtes